it's french technically that's french
[Music]
what's up guys i'm janice pappas i'm
back to answer the internet check out my
special mom love on youtube it's free so
that's a good thing your girlfriend
keeps nagging you to get healthy and go
to the gym with her would you lose a few
pounds
or break up with her i'm losing a few
pounds i'm not i'm not breaking up or
i'm too old i'm not doing this again
dude
yeah my wife could cheat on me i'll just
be like you know what move the guy in
with us we'll tell the neighbors we're
feminist mormons so it's not weird
who's more dominant
kenyans and marathons or indians and
spelling bees
all right that's a simple one it's
indians and spelling bees they are the
kenyan runners of spelling there's a
billion of them so it's like there's
like three kenyans i think that have
gotten proper nutrition and are running
so in fact did you just describe them as
the kenyan runners oh doesn't that mean
it's a tie you're right it's a tie i
mean let's be honest you can destr you
could describe the kenyans and marathons
as the indians and spelling bees or you
could do the vice versa yeah they're
both crushing it all right would you
take a million dollars to be one of the
picket people for the westboro baptist
church during a fallen
soldier's funeral a million dude i would
take 5 000 bucks actually agree with
them you catch me at a very good time
westbrook
church i'll do it for a bitcoin and
they're worthless
if you had to go to war
would you choose to go during the middle
ages the revolutionary war
or world war one i'm gonna answer this
strictly on hygiene i'm going world war
one okay because at least they had like
showers at that point and um that's it
but then you got the chemical war you
could die i'd rather be able to numb
myself if i got to get something cut off
so i'm going with world war one because
revolutionary where everyone smelled
like diarrhea
uh if you could get [ __ ] faced with any
u.s president who would it be donald
trump baby
we'd be talking about nuclear secrets
and mar-a-lago [ __ ] prostitutes
[ __ ] on the phone with putin it would
be a blast who's the number one
celebrity or athlete you want to see
come back
to
life
uh i'm gonna go with mickey mantle
because
that's again a good time dude now you
know what my wheelhouse is [ __ ] cigars
alcohol
irresponsibility i mean you know [ __ ]
what am i going to say ac green so we
could go to church together he's not
dead is he pull the internet would you
rather spend the rest of your life in a
country music video or a rap video again
i'm i'm going with the fun i'm going
with rap videos i mean country music
videos kind of they kind of max out at
beer putting your feet in the sand and
uh a nice a nice cold beer did i say or
a truck so you got a truck you got a
beer and you got your feet in the sand
if i'm in a rap video i got guns
i got a lot of bling and i got
prostitutes if you don't got prostitutes
i'm not coming you can tell i'm married
you know cause you prostitutes you they
don't talk they don't tell on you
okay would you rather get caught
masturbating or
[ __ ] your pants in public i think i
would rather get uh
caught masturbating [ __ ] in public
is is pretty that's a pretty bad
situation on a list if you get caught
masturbating in public yeah but i mean
it's embarrassing but you're not a
[ __ ] sex offender they got us on that
list already dude i mean they know yeah
i mean i got an email threatening me the
other day did you ever get that email
where they say we have you masturbating
and they show you the phone number and
they say
don't contact us we'll contact you and i
was like [ __ ] it's the funny thing
because they contacted someone i don't
care dude i don't care they're like oh
we know what you were masturbating too
it's like i've talked about it on a
podcast good luck i hope you enjoyed it
man because
good my wife knows i masturbate i mean
everyone at this point that's like the
least controversial thing that could
happen if there was only one podcast in
the world who would you want the two
co-hosts to be
um i think a great
podcast would be
um
biden and trump that would be great if
they were forced to podcast together
wouldn't it be funny if they turned out
to have like electric chemistry if it
was just that would be hilarious
hi i'm joe and i'm donald and this is
two sides of the coin yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it was like are you debate
points and then yeah it actually works
out well yeah you could do like a good
betting thing it's like will biden make
it to the fifth episode
will trump get arrested before episode
seven it would be kind of like a podcast
on the run that would be a great one
that would be a good one yeah is eiffel
towering a chick with another
guy gay
no
no dude
no i think eiffel towering another guy
with another guy is that gay it's french
technically that's french
thank you for watching answer the
internet please remember to subscribe to
the channel
set reminders with a little bell comment
who you want to see do it and watch all
the other answer the internets i don't
know where anything is so i'm kind of
just moving my hands around but do all
that [ __ ] subscribe comment reminder
watch others you're welcome don't know
why but you're welcome